3 2 com um filho mas um vídeo bem
levinho que me recorde pessoal de quem
fala ataques muito meninos perioli o op
sua voz tem uma mãozinha é não só um
vídeo de hoje eu vou te falar certas
coisas que eu comprei na internet que
supostamente ajudam na cozinha e
melhorar a nossa vida e tornar nossa
vida é mais fácil supostamente então
como esse comportamento eu tive que
comprar para testar mesmo só que
encontrei aqui pleito
eu por exemplo tenho aqui um cortador é
confrangedor
achei fatiador de melancia olha só tem
muita liminar que a lei e porque é que
ser discutido no lance e para tirar
batata na medida para thiago pra você só
encaixar em agosto veio muito forte acho
que vai funcionar o que eu tenho aqui o
time que não esquece que não um cortador
panela encurtador mas é encurtado
anuncia eu não estarei com um cortador
batata e eu acho que dá pra fazer tipos
de fruta clique no play off para ficar
muito bom se bem que eu não vou fritar
vou usar uma vez mais do que isso estão
mais curioso nunca desfez ganha nada com
isso olha só eu não sei mas supostamente
descascar nas ruas vai lá estar pessoal
vamos ver se este produto realmente
cumprem aquilo com o que prometeu e
cumpriu e eu tenho aqui tem um cortador
de ovos olha só meu é muito estranho que
tem uma mãe muito estranho mas fora lá
pessoal e é responsável disse eu quero
te pedir uma coisa muito importante
porque vocês não fizerem um vasto dem
passa por um ótimo ver esse mundo é e
bonita vai explodir como é que vocês
podem evitar isso só vem sendo que um é
que neste vídeo e inscreva se aqui no
canal francês não se inscrever em todas
as minhas fotos portanto só achei muito
líquidos filho mas para nós os produtos
escolhem um parceiro da maçã
o dado escreveu vamos realizar um desvio
para tomá lá pessoal primeiro produto
curta dor de uma senhora com a inscrição
destruindo tanques e armas é e tirar
tudo cruz que tem por dentro e por isso
pensa naquilo no braço frontera mas
pronto para 321 meu deus então entrou
entrou vôo o que é isso
olhei isso resultou mas não só como
ficou essa maçã e agora pessoal esta
supostamente ter paz anunciou compra e
enchei aparelho olha aí mas pessoal
funcionou realmente foi muito fácil de
escola mas ansioso foods prefeito olha
socorrão ii ofereceu o prefeito ficou
uma caixa que baixo nesta época um match
of here to stop só eu todos sabiam
notícia que por muito tempo porque só
encaixar assim que dj tudo clássico
china tcheco não isso que realmente
significa vida no futebol da nossa roupa
[Música]
que ela fundada por um gravado no nosso
primeiro do camaro 2011 a câmera
programa para nós uma curta doença
funcionou durante a próxima hora
presente luz um portador de uma certa
maneira isso aqui dá pra usar muito mais
um bingo vai né brinca ela acha os
conselheiros com casca imaginava nem
natatória anda por aí no catar contra a
lei mas no carro em que ficaram em pé
não não é assim tão estranho câmara está
tudo bem nada contra turno da noite não
acaba nem assim e estou à procura de
histórias empate em 3 2 não vai ser
muito dura
não foi uma caravana eu acho que se
encaixa como esse
acho que enganar chitato de manhã foi é
e será minha semana agora eo ebuddy
certeza não sou cavalos uma data futura
a opel mas vamos lá estava não estava
descarregada 321 esmagou tudo em espécie
uma banana agora a natureza fazer a
prova
assim a paciente tinha junto ao futebol
mas esta sim não é muito útil porque
vocês tragam a valer toda então esta não
é muito útil mas é mais fácil sair de
qualquer forma eu vou governar que eu
vou fazer querem selar o futuro próximo
do mar 2 1
o hertha não para vai para 31
meu deus eu acho que vou curtir a lei
quando o animal como eu votava
e não foi o cubo luta
a última tacada chip outra casa contra
ataque e agora sofre para sua cozinha
aí vai passei muito poder para lá
próximo cortador de unha curta de ontem
que esta prática não sair mas machuquei
achei que eu acho assim está agora só
colocar aqui o ovo que agora em 32 o um
vai cortar o o o expresso não fez nada
como um jogo difícil mas vejam só play o
ovo abrir tudo incrível e um pintinho e
[Música]
321 sério que é um protetor de tomate
final a equipe que eu ganhei 32 para
cuidar ainda que este é o roteiro está
muito aquém não sabe portal tomado por
aí última fatia e do be que falava do
fat wai que merece nem vai ser o nosso o
próximo movimento vai ser o homenageado
é e vai ser difícil o primeiro tem que
arrancar esta vacina é que o do boi
dormir e acordou e mesmo eu gosto muito
agora o pessoal fala que é o produto ou
o portador guiana já olha só como é que
ela vai ser difícil profundidade é muito
bom assim
eu estava vazia pegada de carbono
química dura4 campo-grandense da frança
que o marcão do tororó
após o show conta do ginásio em 32 fuga
[Música]
da prisão comparou a sua avante
continuar faltando apenas dois produtos
para atestar que o cortador de cenoura
para se morar aqui afirma absurdo
olha isso minar a senhora tá muito lucro
[Música]
tudo foi escrito como seguranças que
isso é punição a senhora fox não tem a
movimentação em cumprimento a descrição
do facebook de fato bizarro quem mora lá
pessoal só tenha que o curto do lancia e
vamos lá só você acha que vai funcionar
muito e melancia
vocês acham que não vai funcionar como
feijão 3 foi com um pouco os cortes mas
não fui só eu acho que vai pintar em
breve
daí
ai meu deus está com a sua quase só vou
voltar é porque eu acho que eu comprei
uma melancia muito bota preso em outubro
[Aplausos]
uma em cada lance está cortada mas só
nós já estamos de que dois dos produtos
e isso aqui não deu certo porque eu acho
que o lance era muito grande mas foi uma
moça porque não acho que resulta
português é funcional por poucos muito
tempo executado na franquia onze é o
único que eu cheguei muito podre é o da
banana vai ser continuado mas só vamos
pra que vocês tenham gostado que desse
vídeo já sabem deixem muito líquido e
isso não foi inscrito no canal quem
escreveu é esse envolvimento pessoal
fique mais próxima
[Música]